ich denke wir können beginnen ich möchte
zusammen mit
toll einzuführen
sie begrüßen zu dieser tagung wir freuen
uns dass so viele gekommen sind der raum
ist voll das ist auch nicht immer der
fall hier das park gedanken zunächst zur
einleitung sagen zum begriff des geistes
dem diese zweitägige tagung gewidmet
sein wird
es gibt wohl kaum einen anderen
philosophischen begriff der so
bedeutungsschwer und zugleich so wenig
spezifisch zu teilen scheint jedenfalls
wie der begriff des geistes er ließe
sich darin höchstens mit dem begriff des
absoluten vergleichen
und tatsächlich ist ekel sophie gerade
durch den verbund beide begriffe in
absoluten geist berühmt und berüchtigt
das wort geheizt umfasst mehr deutsche
sprache ein bedeutung spect rum das auf
den ersten blick ganz unterschiedliche
bereiche betrifft und nur schwer einen
roten faden oder zusammenhang erkennen
lässt so kann geist einerseits
allgemeine phänomene wie etwa das
charakteristikum einer bestimmten
sprache historischen epoche nation oder
religion bedeuten
zum anderen kann das wort aber auch
gerade die individuelle intellektualität
und aktion bezeichnen
etwa dann wenn jemand geistreich genannt
zu werden verdient weil er gewisse
zusammenhänge und einheit erblickt wo
andere nur vereinzelung und trennung
vermeiden
das deutsche wort geist und fasst die
bedeutung der griechischen wörtern logos
team aus da immer und auch psychisch
entsprechend dem lateinischen wörter wie
ratio ritus animus anima genius und
sensus nur einige zu nehmen
der in münchen geborene philosoph max
scheler hat aufgrund dieser polyphonie
des wortes auch davon gesprochen das
zitat zelte mit einem worte so viel
unfug getrieben worden ist wie die mit
mit dem wort geist ein worte wider sagt
bei dem sich nur wenige etwas bestimmtes
denkt gemein ist allen diesen verwendung
weisen vom geist dennoch eine
spezifische form von rationalität oder
besser integrität die einheiten der
vielheit deutlich und charakteristisch
macht diese individualität und
bestimmtheit
im doppelten sinne des wortes
aufzuweisen die zu haben und unter
beweis zu stellen
gleich einen aha effekt könnte als ein
spezifikum des geistes gelten
oder anders formuliert derjenige ist
geistreichen den geist einer sache
bestimmt erkennt und sich darin mit der
sache zugleich verbindet geist wäre so
verstanden nicht mehr etwas nicht so
etwas bestimmtes dinglich in der
weltlich vorkommendes zum ganz allgemein
die bedingungen der möglichkeit von
bestimmt zeit von 10 und
verständlichkeit solcher phänomene die
ansonsten stumm und taub bleibt jemand
ist in diesem verständnis verfolgt genau
dann geistreich wenn ihr den toten
buchstaben semantisch vitalisierung und
in eine beziehungsgeflecht transparent
werden
es werde sondern besonders die sprache
unter 10 vorne sprechen ein zeichen von
geist aber auch der sinn für geschichte
und ganzheitliche bildung im sinne
dieser doppelten bedeutung von
integrität steht geist damit im vollzug
des verbinden von individualität und
allgemeinheit und zwar synchron
sprachlich die diakon durch geschichte
und bildung
aufgrund seiner bedeutungsschwere und
semantischer über determination war und
ist der begriff des geistes sie doch
nicht selten zu knüpfen ausgesetzt
gewesen die ihn auf einem bestimmten
gegenstands bereich einschränken und
somit domestizieren wollen
der geist von bestimmten richtungen
wählen
doch winde drehen schnell und schlagen
um so dass er am besten einen klaren
begriff aufgehoben wäre
die unmissverständlich und eindeutig ist
der versuch einer begrifflichen
domestizierung des geistes hatte gar
nicht selten dazu geführt dass
semantisch beschnitten wurde
etwa dann wenn er auf das
angelsächsische wort meint reduziert
wurde
welches überwiegend psychologisch
kommentiert gegen die tendenz einer
semantischen reduzierungen wollen die
vortrage der tagung gerade an dieser
bedeutungsschwere des geistes festhalten
ohne dabei jedoch der gefahr zu erliegen
dass geist entweder unbrauchbare wo
gebraucht oder zu einer substanz und
visiert wird in diesem bestreben die
sinnvolle einheit des begriffs
historisch systematisch zu demonstrieren
könnte die tagung am ende performativ at
ausdrückte so verstanden geist bis sein
sein begriff also durch die tat
demonstrieren die tagung zerfällt in
zwei teile am heutigen tag geht es um
die blüte des kreis von kant über fichte
schelling die frühromantik bis hin zu
hegel am ende mit dem vortrag von herrn
professor koch der morgige tag ist der
krise des geistes gewidmet beginnend mit
dem vortrag von herrn profil sorgt
gerhard zu nietzsche und enden im
vortrag von herrn professor thema lean
zu adornos begriff des geistes